safety off safety
off oh
sh get him
girl oh I'm a bad mother first time i'
ever seen this I ain't going to
lie all right look we're in Bay City
Texas welcome with the president the
mayor the king of Bay City that Mexican
OT what's going on baby had to bring
Bole C over here I'm super excited man
California was fun whenever we went over
there yeah we had some good times over
there shroom gummies all that [__] yeah
yeah we're not on any shroom gummies
right now but shroom gummies what we are
going to do is uh go kill some pigs y
going to go kill some pigs out of the
helicopter uh thank y'all for coming
down come to do something yall going to
have fun uh at the same time we're
helping the farmers we're helping the
ranchers down here the Hogs are just
devastating yeah what is it cuz a lot of
people are going to watch this video and
be like you guys are [__] up killing
all these pigs uh what is the purpose
cuz they're like they're invasive right
they're they're invasive they're just
like rats in your pantry man you got to
put out a trap and not a lot of people
understand that I made a business out of
it but we actually have to do this if we
didn't have helicopters and we weren't
doing what we're doing they take over
you [__] me yeah if I have like a
golden retriever running around my land
rip it in half so right now I'm seen to
take out two pits oh yeah oh yeah so
right now we're saving dogs dogs saving
lives appreciate you having
us coming down man someing
man do it nervous bro I me nervous
you're just going to be 20 25 ft in the
air I got a seat belt gun and no seat
belt oh there's no seat belt I'm just
playing there's a seat belt I should
probably put that on huh yeah yeah yeah
seat belts a pain in my ass though I
feel comfortable cuz Ryan's flying this
in flip
flops flying this inpop I've never even
been in a helicopter here we are
baby mother kale we're in the air baby
how you feeling I feel good all right
we're in the plane this is not a plane
it's a helicopter yeah on a way to kill
the pigs boot leg let's go there's
alligators down there too oh like
feasting on all the cows it feels good
up here right K yeah it feels great keep
your eyes out K just where they going to
be fat ass G
holy we are B in the
corner
mother that was that was gnarly you see
him
alligator oh I see him oh you see him K
I see him jump D in the water oh I do
love the taste of Gator nuggets from
Papados they're the best just an update
on the video here we are we are still
looking for
pigs bad
luck I'm sorry fellas look at that
beautiful
beautiful oh look look look right here
right here found some yeah right here
turn around turn around let's go
oh look at this there they go I see him
oh
sh all right let me get
ready
oh got him got
him all right I'm off safety get that
ass K where they at yeah you got a big
one yeah right you saw that big mother
God that [__] was swoll hey yo
what the oh right here kid I'm looking
I'm
looking right here kid right here
kid put him out of his
misery I just want to make sure he's you
know all
right
damn smoke the
pig God Rest his soul those little got
out of there and hi quick yeah up know
what's up safety off safety
off oh
sh get him
B oh I'm a b motherucker I'm a bad
mother let me finish
him I want to take a picture with that
mother let's move his big ass you get
this check this out watch this I'm
looking hold
on holy [__] safety
on
we got a
pig damn that poor
bastard he's done look at this
guy oh that's gnarly oh [__] bro there's
cows
approaching are the cows stinking us
right now emptied his [__] out emptied
his [__]
out you saw the [__] guts of that
[__] I saw it Kev I ain't going
to lie I hit him with one shot and I
emptied his guts out I saw that I saw
the whole [__] laid his [__] out first
shot oh we over the bille look right
here boake K yeah this our Hood right
here so look that water tower you see
that water tower yeah that's the water
tower tatted on me right here yeah
that's B City all right there that music
video M Gordon that's where we shot the
video oh [__] yeah yeah yeah is that a
football stadium over there High School
yes are they playing right now no oh bro
go let's go let's go that's crazy oh
that's hard let's get a video them come
on get me over there man B City y'all
better win tonight boys better win
wo Bas City Texas do y'all's
[__] thing tonight
baby let's go be careful that house man
let's go that's dope let's go the
airport ahead of us yeah right here
yeah there we go we're
back killing [__] God damn it how many P
we only killed like three pigs yeah like
three or four of them but probably
knocked off like five of them cuz
there's a few that I hit but they got
away they did get away we ain't done yet
man we ain't done yet they about to give
us the night
vision
[Music]
Mr Texas himself we're in Bay City God
damn it be careful with their house be
careful the house we're at his nanny's
house I'm in the T-shirt this my nanny
right here so this is my grandma my
dad's mama when my mother passed this is
where I came to live with and I lived
with her in Bay C forever how proud of
you this guy right now I am very proud
of him he is one of my pre Jews in my
life uh Virgil was a challenge growing
up and he is a wonderful Challenge and a
beautiful blessing to you guys thank you
for your support I am so proud of him
was he rapping like would you hear him
rapping oh my goodness let me tell you
Virgil has his books he has been rapping
since he could talk this you rapping
yeah that's crazy
yeah that's when his mom passed away
online of cowboys D these are my the my
Peppa chos and all them they see hold on
get this real quick cuz I be thinking
this shit's just for the [__] camera
bro I come from a bloodline of these
[__] yeah that'd be good yeah
hell yeah I mean this is what we grew up
doing oh they'll never ask me about why
you wear a hat anymore he got Cowboy of
the Year here in cowboy of the decade
Cowboy of the decade right there turn
back
around
o
[Music]
Mike Jones if you're listening to this
thank you for making a young man feel at
home when he was lost in the
world exclusive ass person right there
man I don't think I ready for a human
being like that
baby
all right so I killed two pigs earlier
and I I don't feel great about it I just
have to remember that they're
um they're pest they kill golden
retrievers right so like we're we're
we're like doing God's work right now
we're driving through Bay City shout out
to OT we got to uh hang out with his
family and now we're going to go kill
some more pigs there's going to be bacon
and cheso for breakfast that's all I got
to say ladies and gentlemen that was
really corny but let's go kill some pigs
huh whose property is this the ashc ashc
scer we really are in the middle of
nowhere I mean unless you know where you
are and the city's close everywhere
right here you can follow the moon and
get to the
city that's the sickest [__] I ever
heard you could follow the moon and get
to the city you guys ready yes so what
we do is run in two groups right we're
running four at time M the guns going to
be hot loaded we're going to leave the
thermals on all night we're going to
we'll try to get some video and stuff we
can yes sir are you familiar with the
R15 platform yes sir Kevo is nowadays K
same thing upce fire side side and I
help you right is it bootleg
C give us a couple minutes we get
everything ready we'll get
[Music]
going
we're in Bas the Texas man we going to
have fun tonight baby let's [__] it up
[__] no such thing as a dumb question I
hear you please just ask me or Steve we
do this all the time okay sir yeah no
such thing as a dumb question yeah is
Squirt PE yes hey I'd like to know that
that's that's completely pissed it is
like 7030
P sa is on all brother buddy I can see
everything oh yeah this is Call of Duty
here buddy get all out of your system
before we go hunt cuz kill some [__]
Hogs all right let's go kill these
[__] Hogs right yeah I swear to God
dud you're going to see I'm not bad luck
I'm good luck you're bootleg bad luck
I'm good you bootleg too many goddamn
people K bootleg C that Mexican we're
about to go kill
some who the [__] is doing this bro name
a better podcast and name a better
rapper they don't
exist they don't exist it smells like
[__] cow [__] Hey sir what would
happen if I pet a cow yo Ryan why do we
have to be quiet because these
[__] are smarter than you think
they are the winds that are back they
can hear us and smell us they can smell
your
do about to walk about the cor of a m
okay don't step C [__] I'm excited I Got
a Boner
exide what's
up they're right
there
there's cows
everywhere cow has been killed not a cow
yeah on a dome touch his ear
damn safety off
yep damn now that I sit there and look
at him he look like
bushwig damn that's [__] up he's still
alive no no he dead this is ner one air
butt at a time we're saving one airbud
at a time yeah good hunt gentlemen dirty
ass Hogs tell them boot Lake here [__]
them Hogs [__] them Hogs hey we hey we
got to remember these Hogs are here I'm
trying to take a picture when we get
back look at these [__] Hogs all
right we're driving in the middle of the
night look more pigs to murder because
they are invasive
species and it started to rain that's
all I got onward and
upward
hang on hang
on you better hit that record you're
recording everybody else safe we're
going to go on
three three on three everybody saying
you everybody ready three ready one two
three nailed that
[__] [__] K we got to pick that
body up and bring it back to the other
ones though that's a big ass [__] bro
airbud Killer Hey those right there will
[__] you up I mean look put yeah put
your
finger put your finger on that is toast
bro yeah get his ass H you still alive n
nerv might still be maybe a little
bit might be a little
2 that's what it's going to do the
labador that's what do the airbud airbud
look right there one two three good [__]
boy dude you look like you just got
trying Christ that's bad bad hey how
about waking up like that all over your
face and you didn't even know hey I went
to the bathroom to go pissing I was like
what the [__] you're a sick [__] I'm a
sick
[__] that's a bad one right there we did
it where's Steve at you did it no you
did it he did it you're guilty you're
guilty you did it at least we hav't
heard it like yel you know n we heard it
oh
yeah no [__] way
dude something big got him bro dude way
big got him no that ain't Coy bud no n
look that ain't Co dude that's not Coy
this ain't Coy dude ain't no way it's
coyes check this out y'all let me see
ain't no way a coyote did this in the
time we left look at this in the time we
left we killed we killed this pig not
even two hours ago they ate his whole
guts out don't all the way to his H that
sh emptied his ass out I mean look how
clean everything is too that's how so
what do you think did that did they do
it to both no just one pack of catties
would have tooken both off I don't think
it was a cat oh you know what do you you
think it was CS it's a [__] skin
walker it's the first time i' ever seen
this I ain't going to lie First time i'
seen this no it's first time i' ever
seen this in my life cook liver hold on
here you go
man let's go take two cook liver
ready catch it don't throw that [__] at
me bro we still shooting porn n it's too
foggy we we shooting the dark it was
dangerous this is nut sack Bob here nut
sack Bob slap his balls a no bootle h oh
oh [__] splatted on
me look at this [__] now you're real
Hunter bro kill three pigs got damn it
saved three golden retrievers probably
seven golden retrievers yeah you know we
did God's work and we actually fed a cat
we fed a cat Yeah we actually like see a
cat and a dog cat and a dog coyote yeah
we did good we things today put in some
work we put in work that boy Bole came
all the way from [__] California [__]
with some Texas boys man we did I'm
coming back too easy always good down
here Kevin thank you
sir thank you vir baby